I was going to ask you because I brought
up Mean Girls this is something that is
I think kind of important to your story
which is you played this character who's
now iconic you know Janice Ian there was
a while where you felt like you needed
to now
change the trajectory after that is that
true yes but that was honestly it was
such a different time yeah it also feels
it's so strange it almost feels like
Mean Girls just came out like recently
for whatever reason it's it's I've been
talking to so many kids about Mean Girls
like you know it came out so long ago
now and it's like it never really goes
away but it just feels like there's a
weird Resurgence I think Mean Girls is
one of those films it's a bit there's a
bunch uh not a bunch but they're they're
they're few and far between but it's
like an L for something that's just
gonna keep getting rediscovered and I
think the nice thing is that what it's
talking about and what it's portraying
is something that 14 15 16 year old
girls are dealing with and boys that
felt like a very good depiction of that
very particular thing that so many kids
feel that I think when you're 80 they're
gonna be 16 year olds that are talking
to you about that I think that's
probably true based on what's happening
and it's
it's cool I mean I think I used to be
like I've done other things you know
like right after the years following but
now I'm like I'm very proud to have been
in that and I I just asked the kids like
but how is this
like this High School in Mean Girls
doesn't look anything like your current
high school there's not like a social
media element to any of this like how
what are you identifying with and you're
right it's like you know kids are mean
to other kids that's a it's a beautiful
universal truth it's emotionally
resonant right but I but I also think
the reason I bring it up is I thought
when you went to Masters of Sex that was
because you had you had really carved
out this very enviable Niche and comedy
and then you'd take this big turn which
was worked amazingly well yeah I don't
know how that happened that took a lot
of I would think
that's talk about a brave thing to do I
think that's a brave thing to do oh I
was like
I think it was braver for them honestly
to hire me because I hadn't done
anything dramatic but your previous
question the Mean Girls thing I did feel
like pigeonholed and Typecast but it's
not like that for girls playing like the
weird best friend anymore like the weird
best friend gets to be the central
character now right now that now that's
the star of the show yeah and it
certainly was not that way so yes I
tried to do everything to like go
against that and I like you know got a
spray tan and dyed my hair blonde and
got on this WB show
my I have a friend actress Lindsay Sloan
and we met we've been friends many many
years now but we met in audition rooms
for these WB shows and we both are like
brunette like Jewish girls and we wanted
to get t-shirts made that said I am WB
pretty good
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'd like to buy a wig yeah and like I
definitely did I was like I'm gonna fool
you into thinking I guess I'm not Jewish
or whatever whatever was required I'm
Dutch and I'm from Malibu oh yeah I'm
new here yeah then Masters of Sex like
that whole process was crazy I think I
only got that job because they weren't
shockingly familiar with Smash Hit party
down that like nobody in the world saw
so they just weren't aware like the
producers were not aware of me and I
just remember going out to drinks with
them and just talking about how obsessed
I was with this character and then
it was like the perfect time for me I
just really identified with her and what
she was sort of doing and going through
this this Virginia Johnson and I had to
do a an audition but the audition just
in itself was amazing because they did
like full hair and makeup it was a John
Madden the directors like an incredible
director like such a talent and I did
all the scenes it was just the two of us
in this room we videotaped it and
yeah this older white man
where's the camera trust me there's a
camera
I'm sorry yeah I realized now that
that's what it sounded like yeah and
then it was over and I remember leaving
and feeling like even if I don't get
this roll this that was so incredible
like I don't get to do auditions like
this for these dramatic roles and I had
I didn't think I could do any of this
I didn't think I could like pull this
off in any way and then they
called me and said that they wanted me
to do it and I was like can I go
celebrate I haven't wanted to celebrate
in a while anything
anything and they were like just hold
off a minute and then that minute took
like months and months and months for me
to actually get the part and my agents
were like you need to take this other
job you need to do this other thing and
for whatever reason I was like no I have
to just the possibility of getting to do
this is better than anything else it's
more of a you know real job right which
I don't know if I'd have the balls to do
that now but I knew that like if if I
got to do that it would really change
things for me and it did I now can do
both of those things and I have so many
comedic actress friends who are more
than capable of doing amazing
heavy-hitting dramatic roles they just
don't get the shot at it right so that's
just luck I don't know how that I don't
know how that happened well now I want
to find out why they were waiting so
long yeah yeah I mean I did there is I
know I know why but you probably have to
cut it out oh up to you maybe you could
you know disguise it in some way was
there someone else in the mix there was
a a co-star who was not thrilled with
the idea of me doing it come on yes
it's not
Michael Sheen it wasn't who ended up
being the guy yeah but I don't and I
don't know any of the details of that at
all I just know that there was a lot of
pushback oh God do you want me to cut
that out well I don't know if anybody
knows yeah it doesn't matter no no and I
say we keep it in and also I when I told
you before the podcast that we would
take stuff out yeah you were lying I was
lying cool yeah sometimes we add stuff
in yeah
there's gonna be a voice that doesn't
sound anything like yours it was Michael
Sheen
hey we're blowing up on the Internet
yeah but it's not true it wasn't my
machine I know but [ __ ] it we're blowing
up yeah I don't think Michael Sheen and
Lizzy Kaplan gossip is going to blow up
no you don't understand
I mean yeah it's it's a weird it's a it
was a weird thing and a weird story but
it ended up working out and it ended up
working out wonderfully because it was
Michael Sheen thank God